bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france expliqué de quelle est votre
position à la fcpe sur la levée du
secret médical dans les écoles collèges
et lycées et ce afin de faciliter la
vaccination
écoutez une autre opposition elle est
très simple il s'agit comme vous l'avez
dit du secret médical donc nous pour
nous il est absolument impensable de
lever ce secret médical est donc doute
repasser en fait le droit des élèves
sous même sous couvert de d'un traçage
et que l'on soit en période de pandémie
aujourd'hui ce que l'on demande en fait
au gouvernement c'est de prendre c'est
leur responsabilité c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les vaccins qui sont
obligatoires sont au nombre de 11 si la
copie de 19 ans faisant pas partie si la
levée medica levée du secret médical
doit être fait ça doit être dans ces
conditions et uniquement dans ce cadre
là et on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
porter la levée du secret médical alors
que celle faite le coc u19 ne fait pas
partie des vaccins obligatoires
d'autre part pour notre faim pour notre
fédération c'est aussi un peu un mot un
signal qui est envoyé aux parents qui
est assez négatif puisque les parents
ont signé une décharge sur l'honneur
concernant cette vaccinait cette
vaccination depuis la rentrée donc
quelque part c'est qu'on ne prend pas en
compte cette déclaration sur l'honneur
des parents alors justement ce qu'on
entend beaucoup comme argument cette
dernière heure c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
directeurs d'établissements scolaires ne
peuvent se fier qu'à cette déclaration
sur l'honneur des parents sans aucun
contrôle des résultats de tests
notamment est ce qu'une telle
mesure ne permettrait pas de s'assurer
de limiter les risques de contamination
dans les écoles qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
écoutez je veux dire quelque chose de
très simple en tant que parent moi je
j'en ai assez aussi d'entendre que les
parents sont irresponsables que les
parents sont même quelquefois on l'a
entendu quasiment des menteurs quand
nous nos enfants sont malades qu'ils
aient une gastro qu'ils aient de la
fièvre on ne les envoie pas à l'école
donc aujourd'hui dire que les parents
ont continué fond la déclaration ça
n'est pas totalement vrai c'est quand
même très grave nous aujourd'hui ce que
l'on demande tout simplement
gouvernement c'est de faire confiance
aux parts aux parents aux familles et
donc les de continuer en fait cette
campagne de tests dans les
établissements scolaires parce que
justement plus il est devenu payant à
l'extérieur donc il faut absolument
continuer la campagne de tests continuer
la campagne pour les gestes barrières et
arrêter de faire peser sur les familles
des responsabilités qui ne sont pas les
leurs sur cette levée du secret médical
qui reste à confirmer par les sénateurs
la semaine prochaine le gouvernement
indique que seul le principal où le
proviseur serait au courant avec le
médecin scolaire et pourrait
discrètement écrire aux parents ou bien
les appeler pour leur conseiller de
faire vacciner leurs enfants est ce que
vous entendez cette justification
c'est de nouveau une pression
supplémentaire qu'on met sur les
familles moi je trouve ça quand même
assez extraordinaire
que ce soient toujours les familles qui
est cette pression là depuis le début de
la pandémie ce sont des familles qui ont
été aux côtés des enseignants ce sont
les familles qui ont fait école à la
maison et ce sont les familles qui ont
fait preuve de solidarité pendant la
pandémie donc aujourd'hui
la donne est de dire que les parents
sont irresponsables les parents ne font
pas vacciner leurs enfants mais je
rappelle juste que le vaccin là qu'elle
a commis dix neuf n'est pas un vaccin
obligatoire que c'est un choix qui est
laissée aux familles donc encore une
fois ci il doit y avoir une campagne de
vaccination massive à ce morceau à ce
moment là le gouvernement doit se poser
la question de savoir est ce que ça doit
elle devenir un vaccin obligatoire
ou pas ici ça ne l'est pas il n'y a
aucune raison de mettre la pression sur
les familles merci beaucoup d'avoir pris
le temps de réagir sur notre antenne
lingettes belhassen je rappelle que vous
êtes co présidente de la fcpe